there is a chance those conditions do
cancel the fireworks Extravaganza that's
bringing hundreds of thousands of people
to the strip tomorrow night but Crews we
spoke with say like Jerry they're hoping
and preparing for the best Ryan mathie
takes us 37 floors on top of the
Venetian with these potentials
we're 37 floors above the ground here
getting ready for the return of
America's party it's not a party without
a view check this out this is our view
right now from the Venetian it joins a
roster of eight different strip hotels
that are planning to shoot off fireworks
when the clock strikes midnight and the
New Year I'm joined Now by one of the
guys responsible for all of its
Christopher Gucci Logistics manager for
our Logistics manager for fireworks by
Gucci talk to me the company's been
doing this for 20 years right correct
family's been doing this show for about
20 years now we are anticipating
potentially some different conditions
come Saturday night talk to me about
those weather conditions what
specifically are you guys looking for
when determining whether or not the show
can actually go on right so right now
the main concern is the wind the rain we
can work with rain wind once it hits a
certain point it's very difficult and
unsafe to fire in the high winds so
we're monitoring the winds every day
we're working closely with the local
authorities and working with the
National Weather Service to monitor what
the forecast is going to be like we have
at least an hour up to an hour after
Showtime time to fire the show and if at
one o'clock it still doesn't look like
it's happening then we you know the
authorities have the
um the final say to cancel the show my
cross fingers are getting Tighter and
Tighter we're really hoping that this
goes on Christopher thank you for your
time guys make sure to be tuning in to
eight news now Saturday night even into
Sunday morning as those fireworks
hopefully go off for now reporting live
from the rooftop of the Venetian Ryan
Matthey a news now